welcome back to Las Vegas now United Way
of Southern Nevada the sponsors of this
next segment are inviting us all to make
a difference in the community through an
annual day of caring here to tell us
more is the president and CEO of United
Way of Southern Nevada Julian High
Julian hi hi hi hi Julian I mean Julian
and Jillian I mean there's something at
work here J squared I think we were
meant to meet today absolutely thank you
so much for having me of course thank
you for being here tell us a little bit
about United Way and what you guys do in
the community sure so United Way of
Southern Nevada is a leading convener
collaborator and and partner with
non-profits here in the Southern Nevada
Community meant to help ensure that
those of us most vulnerable in need in
southern Nevada get the help that they
need we work in three primary areas we
work in Workforce Development student
achievement and success and of course
emergency crisis and funding so that our
brothers and sisters across the valley
when they need a helping hand can get it
from United Way and our Associated
partner to agencies well there are
organization has been around for a while
and you are also celebrating you said
this is the seventh year of the day of
caring right yes I'm super thrilled to
be here to talk a little bit about day
of caring it's this is our seventh
annual day of caring and it's held this
next this Friday this Friday coming up
quickly this Friday coming up very fast
yes my team will remind me of that but
we're having a death caring starting at
8 30 a.m at Stoney's at Town Square and
we're so grateful to our sponsors and in
Sony's because they're giving us a
beautiful inside space to hold our day
of caring and we're also very grateful
to our PNC sponsor and Marta and Stefan
Schmidt who are also sponsoring day of
caring for us so what does the day
entail kind of run us through it and
also how we can get involved sure so
first of all the easiest way to get
involved is to go to
uwsn.org curing to look up all the
Myriad of volunteer projects that we'll
be having around throughout the valley
we have over 50 projects set up already
and Counting I hope and so we kick off
at Sony's at 8 30 a.m with a little
music a little breakfast a little
Fellowship Community ship and then we
send everyone out at 10 A.M to uh to
work on the volunteer projects wow okay
so it's a day of fun but it's also so
much more than just fun it's about
giving back to the community and anyone
can take part in it anyone can take part
in it all they have to do is go to
uwsn.org caring to sign up for the
projects or they can create their own
project which is a lovely thing for
families or school or schools or or
giving societies however you'd like to
be participating to let our neighbors
know that they're not alone and that
there is care for them throughout this
Valley on this day well what a great
message Julian thank you so much for
being here and congratulations and thank
you for everything that you do in our
community and if you guys would like
more information it's all on your screen
here thank you to United Way of Southern
Nevada for sponsoring this segment day
of caring is happening this weekend
that's right at Stoney's of rock and
Country for more information you can
visit that website right there on your
screen
uwsn.org caring Las Vegas now we'll be
right back